pourvu que ça dure vous est présenté par
écho DDS éco-organismes qui agit pour
une économie respectueuse de
l'environnement
[Musique]
bonjour nouveau numéro de pourvu que ça
dure l'émission qui rend les
correspondances sur Public Sénat Chris
sanitaire crise climatique crise sociale
en assiste depuis quelques années un
mouvement de transformation des
entreprises nombreux sont celles qui ont
décidé de s'engager en faveur du climat
et du bien-être de leur salarié pour en
parler nous serons avec l'un des
dirigeants les plus engagés en faveur de
la Responsabilité Sociétale des
Entreprises Pascal de Murger le
directeur général de la MAIF nous dira
comment doit se comporter un patron qui
se veut responsable et puis pour aider
les sociétés à se transformer il existe
des outils c'est le cas de la plateforme
vendredi qui permet salarié et à leurs
dirigeants de s'engager en faveur de
cause utile mais tout d'abord cette
question une entreprise qui intègre ses
exigences environnementales et sociales
peut-elle devenir plus performante
réponse ma
[Musique]
pendant très longtemps les entreprises
étaient uniquement focalisées sur des
objectifs de performance et de
rentabilité Paul gad El bonjour bonjour
merci d'être là directeur des études de
l'Institut Choiseul selon vous une
entreprise au désormais pleinement
s'engager dans le domaine
environnemental social parce qu'ils
entreprises qui ne le fait pas elle
risque carrément de disparaître est-ce
que vous n'y avez pas un peu fort non
vous avez raison de le poser comme ça
c'est une question maintenant de survie
et de pérennité de l'entreprise sur le
long terme
la dynamique de ce qu'on appelle la RSE
ça fait maintenant plusieurs dizaines
d'années que c'est en route il est
responsabilité sociale les entreprises
exactement responsabilité sociale
sociétale l'environnemental ça englobe
beaucoup de choses il y a une
accélération quasi exponentielle
décennie après décennies et maintenant
année après année presque et
face à la fois aux limites planétaires
qui s'impose à tous et notamment aux
entreprises face à l'accepter
l'acceptabilité sociale sociétale des
activités économique et face aussi au
cadre réglementaire qui se contraignent
de plus en plus ce qu'on appelle la RSE
en fait ce qui est la le mouvement de
transition vers plus de durabilité c'est
désormais un enjeu de survie de
pérennité pour les entreprises mais en
2019 avant la crise sanitaire ce
mouvement il était pas si massif que ça
une étude Accenture a montré que
seulement 48% les entreprises avaient
initié une démarche responsable est-ce
qu'il y a vraiment une accélération
après la crise sanitaire il y a une
accélération par la crise ça c'est sûr
la crise sanitaire ça a été un événement
soudain externe qui a mis tout le
système économique et tout le système
capitaliste en fait sous tension et sous
stress et donc en fait ça ça a fait
prendre conscience des fortes
dépendances des entreprises par rapport
à leur partie prenante et par rapport à
l'environnement et ça fait prendre
conscience des fortes vulnérabilité des
acteurs économiques donc ça a été un
mouvement d'accélération des transitions
environnementales et des transformations
des modèles ça c'est sûr mais
faut pas non plus surestimer l'impact de
la crise c'est un bon moment ouais
absolument c'est un moment de long terme
quoi qu'il arrive la crise c'est un
point focal qui a un petit peu hystérisé
tous ces sujets là mais on le voit après
la crise avec la crise énergétique les
chocs géopolitique avec la guerre en
Ukraine ce sont aussi des mouvements qui
tendent à accélérer cette transition
après de quoi est-ce qu'on parle juste
quand on évoque l'entreprise responsable
il y a plein de termes il y a plein de
sigles la RSE a raison d'être
entreprises à mission le critères ESG on
se dit c'est un peu flou et il y a un
petit côté fourre-tout non alors on peut
le penser la RSE c'est vraiment ce qui
est englobe tout et maintenant ça ne
veut plus dire grand chose la RSE est la
responsabilité sociale des entreprises
en fait il s'agit juste de la première
pierre à l'édifice exactement de fond
elle est pas une espèce de formule
qui quelque part n'engage pas au-delà de
la bonne intention qui n'engage pas plus
que ça l'entreprise absolument la RSE ça
désigne juste une transformation de
modèles et une et un désir de de réduire
son impact environnemental absolument ça
rejoint les ça rejoints la communication
ça rejoint aussi le marketing on va
peut-être en parler ensuite la RSE c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui englobe tout
si on veut ensuite davantage dans
l'opérationnel vous avez parlé de raison
d'être et d'entreprises à mission ça
c'est un cadre bien défini en France qui
a été instauré par la loi 2019 la loi
pacte la raison d'être ça permet à une
entreprise de définir une raison d'être
c'est à dire au-delà de son but purement
lucratif de son objet social qui est de
faire du profit il s'agit de dire que
l'entreprise agit pour le bien commun
pour moins d'impact négatif davantage
d'impact positif c'est une attention à
qu'il y a beaucoup d'entreprises
aujourd'hui plein qui qui publient des
raisons d'être c'est très en vogue
c'est souvent pétri évidemment de bonnes
intentions mais là encore dans quelle
mesure ça les engage alors la raison
d'être en soi ça ne les engage pas si ce
n'est la parole donnée mais elles
peuvent les entreprises peuvent
s'engager et se lier les mains entre
guillemets en devenant entreprises à
mission ça c'est aussi quelque chose
quelque chose qui est assez au dessus
c'est le grand d'après c'est le CRAN
d'après pour justement s'engager et
mettre sa peau sur la table comme on dit
il s'agit en fait en devenant entreprise
à mission c'est de modifier les statuts
de l'entreprise c'est de définir une
raison d'être d'accoler des objectifs
sociaux et environnementaux à cette
raison d'être et de s'engager à suivre
l'exécution de ces objectifs la comité
de mission absolument un comité de
mission pour certaines entreprises et
les plus celles qui ont plus de 55
salariés et en fait ce statut
d'entreprise à mission c'est plus que un
élément de communication c'est plus
qu'un badge c'est plus crédible on va
dire c'est plus crédible et c'est
vraiment lié au déploiement opérationnel
de l'entreprise alors il y a une autre
notion qui revient de plus en plus c'est
celle de leadership responsable et je
trouve que vous avez publié une étude
vous dressez justement ce espèce de
portrait-robot aujourd'hui du leader
responsable quelles sont les qualités
qu'il doit absolument requérir
absolument on a on a construit une étude
institut Choiseul où on est interrogé
une vingtaine de décideurs de haut
niveau donc dirigeant d'entreprises
françaises c'était une sorte de coup de
sonde à l'instant T pour voir comment
dans le capitalisme français aujourd'hui
comment les dirigeants avaient pris
conscience et qu'est-ce qu'il faisait
pour transformer leurs entreprises vers
davantage de durabilité et donc on a
interrogé notamment Brice rocher de du
groupe rocher pour une Poirson d'accord
Mathias vicherat Sciences Po ou Isabelle
Didier de kering par exemple et par un
certain nombre d'entretiens et la
remontée terrain de de baisse practice
on a essayé de définir ce que pouvait
être le leadership responsable pourquoi
leadership responsable parce qu'il
s'agit d'engager les entreprises qui
sont des mastodontes parfois vers un
chemin de durabilité de réduction
d'impact de transformation des modèles
et donc ça ça part par le haut et ça ça
demande quelqu'un au quotidien
responsable au quotidien le leader
responsable il se trouve en fait dans un
une juxtaposition d'enjeux et d'impact
croisés parce que c'est ça en fait la
RSE c'est prendre en compte davantage
que le profit c'est prendre en compte
toutes les relations avec les parties
prenantes dans un écosystème
client exactement les investisseurs
institutionnels investisseurs privés
l'État le cadre réglementaire les
concurrents donc c'est beaucoup de
choses qu'est-ce qui pousse qu'est-ce
qui contraint les leaders à devenir plus
responsable est-ce que le contexte de
pénurie de main d'oeuvre peut jouer
aussi ou à la marge ou réellement
absolument je pense qu'ils jouent
vraiment de manière centrale on l'a vu
maintenant auprès des étudiants auprès
de ceux qui sortent des grandes écoles
aujourd'hui
c'est plus le salaire qui compte même si
en période d'inflation il compte quand
même mais c'est la quête de sens et la
quête de responsabilité on l'a vu par un
certain nombre d'initiatives et
notamment le Manifeste pour un réveil
écologique qui était signé par des
dizaines de milliers de d'étudiants
l'impact environnemental et social d'une
entreprise aujourd'hui c'est un critère
fondamental pour que des étudiants
sortis d'école si engagent Brice Rocher
a une excellente expression dans le
rapport Choiseul il dit la raison d'être
d'une entreprise c'est la raison d'y
être et ça j'aime bien le sujet en fait
la raison d'être ça permet de de reposer
les bases d'une entreprise et
d'expliquer pourquoi on y est pourquoi
on travaille à ce projet commun qui est
le projet de toute entreprise
organisation il y a un autre
enseignement dans votre étude c'est le
fait d'adopter une stratégie RSE c'est
gagnant aussi pour l'entreprise parce
que les salariés on se dit sont plus
motivés et donc plus performant eux
aussi c'est une réalité ça ouais c'est
une réalité la RSE c'est un levier de
rentabilité sur la fidélisation des
collaborateurs vous l'avez dit sur la
productivité parce qu'ils sont plus
engagés c'est aussi un levier de
rentabilité purement économique sur
justement le la gestion des ressources
la location des ressources la réduction
des déchets donc ce n'est pas seulement
une contrainte qui vient de l'externe ce
mouvement de durabilité c'est une
transformation des modèles qui est aussi
rentable c'est ça qui est important de
montrer allez merci beaucoup pour Gadel
merci à vous vous êtes directeur des
études de l'Institut Choiseul alors
c'est l'un des dirigeants précurseurs en
matière de Responsabilité Sociétale son
groupe on a des premiers voire opté pour
le statut d'entreprise à mission le
patron de la MAIF et notre invité
[Musique]
c'est un patron qui colle bien au slogan
de sa compagnie assure militant un
dirigeant engagé qui a la conviction que
la performance d'une entreprise reposera
plus que jamais sur ses choix éthiques
parce qu'elle le murgeait bonjour
bonjour David merci d'être là avec nous
directeur général de la MAIF est-ce que
quand même c'est pas plus facile d'être
un patron responsable quand on est à la
tête vous voyez venir d'un établissement
mutualiste et qu'on n'a pas des
actionnaires à rémunérer alors à la fois
oui et non non parce que nous sommes une
entreprise plongée dans la concurrence
sur le marché de l'assurance et la
concurrence est vive sur ce marché
derrière en face de nous il y a des des
entreprises mondiales des axad et
alliances des généralistes qui qui sont
de très grandes entreprises et donc on
est soumis évidemment au même contrat
d'économique et en même temps c'est un
peu plus facile parce que
on n'a pas effectivement d'actionnaires
à servir on n'a pas de dividende à
verser on n'a pas de compte à rendre
tous les trimestres on n'a pas de cours
de bourse à défendre
et ça ça change énormément de choses
parce que ça veut dire qu'on n'est pas
prisonnier de court terme on est on peut
diriger l'entreprise avec une
perspective de long terme et c'est vrai
qu'il y a des choix qui sont pertinents
pour l'entreprise pertinent on en
parlera sans doute pour la planète pour
la société qui nécessite d'avoir une
vision de lanterne bon est-ce qu'être un
patron responsable c'est ne pas gagner
des millions d'euros par an est-ce que
ça vous choque des rémunérations citera
pas de nom de patron du CAC40 qui gagne
plusieurs millions ou dizaines de
millions d'euros chaque année alors la
question est pas tant de savoir si ça me
choque que
de comprendre les conséquences de ces
rémunérations pour moi il y a deux
sujets distincts et d'abord
effectivement le montant de la
rémunération en gros ce qu'on appelle le
ratio d'équité c'est à dire le rapport
entre le salaire moyen dans l'entreprise
et le salaire le plus élevé ce ratio
d'équité chez nous il est de 13
vous l'avez défini comme ça
il y a pas de normes il y a pas de norme
il y a pas de norme il se fait qu'il est
très c'est un constat il y a moyen en
France il est en moyenne dans les
entreprises du CAC 40 il est supérieur à
quand vous gagnez dans une journée ce
qu'un de vos collaborateurs gagne
quasiment dans une année
je suis pas sûr qu'on fasse exactement
partie du même corps social de
l'entreprise qu'on est le même sentiment
d'appartenance et diriger un corps
social dirigé des équipes nombreuses
quand on a pas cette conviction qu'on
partage au fond le même destin et la
même réalité je pense que c'est
extrêmement difficile avoir un
leadership sur un corps social auquel
les gens n'ont pas le sentiment que vous
appartenez c'est quelque chose de très
difficile standard du marché aussi des
boîtes du CAC40 ce sont des
multinationales et les salaires sont
alignés sur d'autres multinationales
italienne espagnole américaine oui mais
c'est le marché enfin c'est le jeu du
marché si on veut s'y prêter
il y a d'excellents dirigeants qui qui
gagnent beaucoup moins regardez les
entreprises publiques les entreprises
publiques vous le savez le plafond
400000 euros voilà alors le plafond pour
le coup est très bas et en même temps et
en même temps il y a des dirigeants de
très grande qualité à la tête des
entreprises publiques jusqu'à quelle
hauteur ou à quelle hauteur un patron
responsable doit rémunérer en tout cas
indexer la part de variables de la
rémunération la sienne et des
collaborateurs sur des enjeux ou des
critères non financiers
extra-financières pour moi ça doit être
ça doit être de l'ordre d'au moins la
moitié du de la rémunération
pour tout le monde c'est le cas pour
tous ceux qui perçoivent une
rémunération variable c'est désire un
nombre assez limité de personnes en
réalité en revanche il y a participation
et intéressement pour l'ensemble des
collaborateurs avec des critères de
durabilité
des critères d'impact et d'ailleurs quel
critères en prendre effectivement en
termes de critères extra-financiers pour
les la partie variable des rémunérations
c'est les émissions de CO2 les alors ça
peut être effectivement des critères
environnementaux émissions de CO2 c'est
c'est typiquement typiquement un critère
possible nous on ne se contente pas de
ça on a ce qu'on appelle un cadre
iptique c'est-à-dire une vision assez
globale de la performance de
l'entreprise reposant sur quatre axes
d'abord l'épanouissement des
collaborateurs parce que enfin je trouve
que ça n'a pas de sens de chercher à
avoir un impact positif sur
l'environnement ou sur la société c'est
comment on mesure par plein de
d'indicateurs possibles soit des
indicateurs purement quantitatifs par
exemple le taux d'absentéisme soit des
des indicateurs reposant sur des
enquêtes que l'on conduit régulièrement
auprès des de l'ensemble des des
salariés ensuite il y a une famille
d'indicateurs sur la satisfaction de nos
clients de nos sociétaires et ça c'est
important parce que derrière d'abord
prouve que l'on a bien répondu à leur
attente et puis derrière il y a la
fidélité l'entreprise et ça c'est un
véritable moteur et de développement et
économique il y a bien sûr la
performance de l'entreprise entendue au
sens traditionnel des grands indicateurs
notamment financiers ou autres et puis
il y a effectivement l'impact sur la
société et sur l'environnement
financière autant d'importance que
l'extra financier donc chez anaïf
l'extra financier autant d'importance
que le film
et
celle extra-financier je crois qui en
grande partie nourrit la performance de
l'entreprise en réalité on peut être
côté en bourse c'est tenir ce discours
là je crois à partir du moment où on
crée de la performance par des
engagements aussi bien auprès des
collaborateurs des clients que de la
société à partir du moment où ça génère
de la performance bien sûr on peut être
côté en bourse c'est ça rapporte à tout
le monde y compris aux actionnaires
quand on en a être responsable ces
pensées tout autant quand on est un
patron à l'intérêt donc de ses clients
tout autant que ses collaborateurs
et moi je dirais que ça commence à
débute par ses collaborateurs
on a à la MAIF et ça a été notre notre
première étape il y a une dizaine
d'années changer radicalement le style
de management de l'entreprise et la
culture de l'entreprise et on est passé
ce qu'on appelle chez nous le management
par la confiance ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire au fond faire de
l'épanouissement des collaborateurs dans
leur dans leur exercice professionnel
quotidiens dans leur métier faire de
l'épanouissement des collaborateurs
l'objectif numéro un voire même
l'objectif exclusif du management et si
vous vous fixez ça comme objectif que se
passe-t-il vous créez les conditions
pour qu'effectivement il soit épanoui ça
veut dire à la fois
faire comprendre le sens de la mission
de chacun et la contribution de du
travail de chacun ça veut dire
évidemment accorder un très haut niveau
de confiance à ses collaborateurs et
faire en sorte que il ne soit pas là
simplement pour handic la confiance
n'exclut pas le contrôle
ouais mais ça c'est c'est vraiment trop
court comme comme expression la
confiance est une confiance a priori et
ça veut dire un très haut niveau de
délégation en réalité faire en sorte que
les collaborateurs ne soient pas là
simplement pour exécuter des process qui
ont été inventés par d'autres mais
véritablement pour apporter les
solutions qui leur paraissent les
meilleures à une situation à une
situation donnée et puis le management
par la confiance c'est aussi essayer de
créer dans l'entreprise des relations
qui reposent beaucoup plus sur
finalement sur l'attention que je vais
porter à l'autre que sur la compétition
sur sur la concurrence que se passe-t-il
quand vous faites ça il se passe que
effectivement et on le mesure les
collaborateurs sont sont beaucoup plus
épanouis mais en même temps ils sont
infiniment plus motivés ils trouvent du
sens alors à leur travail et étant plus
motivé ils sont également plus engagés
et vous créez comme ça de la performance
est-ce qu'il y a le patron responsables
parce qu'il y a de Murger c'est ne pas
trop augmenter le prix de ces produits
de ses services en inflation ferrages un
patron responsable ne fait pas de profit
de crise de profitent pas de la crise
pour augmenter ses prix et faire plus de
marge bon écoutez il y a deux manières
de réagir face à une crise et je vais
vous donner deux illustrations la
première manière ce qu'on a fait lorsque
il y a eu le début de la crise sanitaire
le début du covid et vous vous souvenez
tous les franchises pas les franchises
mais les primes exactement bien sûr je
me souviens très bien je sais pas si
vous vous souvenez 17 mars souvent on a
dit super coups marketing 17 mars 2020
le président de la République prend la
parole et annonce le confinement le
lendemain matin évidemment on prend le
bas de combat il fallait que le
lendemain tout le monde reste chez soi
et que l'entreprise tourne je réuni mon
équipe et la première chose que je leur
dis avant de rentrer dans les conditions
considérations opérationnelles la
première chose que je leur dis c'est
on ne sait pas du tout qu'elle va être
quelles vont être les conséquences de
cette crise en revanche il y a une chose
dont je suis certain c'est qu'il est
hors de question que nous tirions à
quelconque bénéfice de la crise parce
que il y a des gens il y a des
entreprises qui vont souffrir il est
hors de question qu'on en tire profit
donc vous remboursez une dizaine de
jours après on se rend compte évidemment
que les voitures qui circulent et donc
on se dit qu'on a aucune légitimité à
conserver les primes d'assurance et on
les rembourse pendant
sur la période correspondant ou à la
période de
quand je vous dis que beaucoup de gens a
postériori que c'est un super coup de
pub un super couloir c'était vraiment
pas l'objet c'était vraiment pas assez
c'est vraiment pas ce qui nous a ce qui
nous a animé en revanche je peux vous
dire que le développement de la MAIF
depuis cette période n'a jamais été
historiquement depuis 1934 aussi aussi
élevé parce que oui ça crée et tant
mieux un mouvement de sympathie
finalement pour pour cette marque qui a
osé faire ça et qui a été la seule à le
faire quelle a été votre cheminement
c'est-à-dire que avant d'avoir cette
fibre qu'on sent sincère sociale la
société à l'écologie il y a eu un déclic
dans votre vie pardon pro peut-être
perso qui vous en conduit à
rompre avec vos habitudes d'avant et
plusieurs déclics perso moi j'ai trois
enfants qui maintenant sont grands entre
18 et 25 ans et à l'époque on se parle
il y a une petite quinzaine d'années ou
une grosse dizaine d'années
clairement j'ai bien senti que
ce que je pouvais de temps en temps leur
raconter sur mon travail ne les
intéressait absolument pas et que
finalement le monde auquel que je
contribuais à perpétuer n'était pas le
monde dans lequel ils avaient envie de
vivre et forcément c'est un déclic c'est
une prise de conscience et puis pendant
longtemps moi j'ai été enfin pendant
longtemps en tout cas au début j'ai été
comme beaucoup de patrons un patron
tiraillé tiraillé entre l'exigence de
performance et l'envie de
parce qu'il faut la personne mais
absolument et alors ma responsabilité de
patron je l'assume complètement j'ai
aussi la responsabilité de la pérennité
de l'entreprise et donc de sa
performance il y a aucun doute là-dessus
et c'est très très clair tiraillé entre
la performance d'un côté et la volonté
de l'autre effectivement d'essayer
d'avoir l'impact de le plus positif
possible ce tiraillement je ne dépassé
que le jour où j'ai compris que en
réalité c'est en ayant ces engagements
et cette recherche d'impact que l'on
pouvait créer encore plus de performance
et là ça change absolument tout et notre
stratégie aujourd'hui notre modèle
d'entreprise repose sur cette équation
et ça infuse dans toutes les strates de
l'entreprise que à sa tête il faut qu'il
y a un leader responsable mais après
transmettre aux équipes tout à fait et
effectivement on demande et on
sensibilise et on forme l'ensemble des
équipes et on leur demande au fond de
reconsidérer la manière dont ils
exercent leur propre métier en fonction
de l'impact que ça va générer les trois
mots trois épithètes qui définissent le
mieux un patron un leader responsable
deux mots ça me suffit aussi
d'abord sincère
on ne fait rien de solide on ne fait
rien durable et on ne fait rien que l'on
puisse partager si à pas une très une
très grande sincérité autrement on fait
des choses à moitié qui n'ont absolument
aucun aucun intérêt donc sincère sincère
je crois qu'il faut parfois
une forme de radicalité en tout cas la
capacité à
dépasser des consensus habituels
à prendre des décisions qui sont
véritablement en rupture et pour ça il y
a besoin oui d'une forme de radicalité
dans sa manière de penser allez merci
pour cet entretien Pascal de Murger donc
directeur général de la MAIF merci à
vous merci à vous bah justement pour
aider les sociétés et leurs dirigeants a
réussir ce défi de la RSE il existe des
outils focus sur l'un d'entre eux qui
implique toutes les parties prenantes de
l'entreprise
[Musique]
et oui changer le monde sans changer de
travail c'est le credo de la start-up
vendredi bonjour Émilie alors tout
démarre en 2015 et vendredi à l'époque
n'est qu'une association mais son
fondateur Félix de Mons il voit grand et
oui quand il fonde vendredi est encore
étudiant et à l'époque des termes comme
RSE critères ESG ou raison d'aide des
entreprises ce sont des termes qui
évidemment ne sont pas du tout à la mode
lui il a envie d'être une partie de la
solution face à l'urgence sociale et
environnementale il est convaincu
finalement qu'il faut arrêter d'opposer
intérêt général et le profit de
l'entreprise et donc tout commence avec
les stagiaires et oui on les appelle les
stages partagés dans les entreprises
peuvent proposer à leur stagiaires de
s'impliquer un jour par semaine dans des
causes qui leur tiennent à cœur
l'équation elle est vraiment gagnante et
stagiaires se sentent utile et motivés
donc plus performants les entreprises
elles sont satisfaites et du coup
demandeuses pour leur propre salarié et
c'est ainsi que l'association se mue en
startup avec sa propre plateforme
d'engagement exactement très vite elle
est contactée par les équipes RH et RSE
des entreprises des pour nous comme
Danone Suez PwC sopra Steria payfit
manomano ou encore swae s'abonne à la
plateforme tout simplement pour être
aidé dans leur démarche RSE bon notre
émission aujourd'hui se place du point
de vue des dirigeants de quels outils et
bénéficie-t-il pour transformer leur
entreprise alors au-delà du classique
accompagnement pour se mettre en
conformité avec les normes RSE il y a
tout un soutien aux associations c'est
d'ailleurs la mission historique de
vendredi les collaborateurs peuvent
prendre sur l'entente de travail tout en
étant payé c'est important de signaler
c'est l'entreprise qui finance tout ça
alors cela peut aller de 1 à 10 jours
par an en fonction de ce que vous
accorde votre boîte et le choix ne
manque pas parmi les deux mises
associations partenaires alors vous
pouvez par exemple donner un soutien
logistique à l'association Mamama qui
vient en aide aux mers isolé participé à
la collecte de déchets aux côtés de
l'association soft rider ou au
distribution de repas chaud aux côtés de
la soupe pourquoi pas vous engager dans
des missions un petit peu plus longues
de programmes de mentorat pour aider des
jeunes à dans la vie active ou tout
simplement mettre vos compétences
informatiques par exemple au service de
la création du site web du Nassau l'idée
en creux c'est que tout le monde mette
la main à la pâte les salariés comme les
dirigeants bon il y a un deuxième outil
Émilie qui est important c'est la
sensibilisation des teams de la team des
équipes exactement ça passe par des
défis ludiques et pédagogiques des
parcours fléchés des tutoriels des quiz
sur des possibles à la biodiversité ou
handicap ou encore à la parité c'est
très facile en plus ça se fait en
quelques clics sur son appli ou son ordi
au bureau comme à la maison les salariés
qui peuvent aussi être amenés à se
déplacer à l'occasion des
traditionnelles on connaît tous ces team
building là vendredi est partenaire par
exemple de l'association la sauge qui
organise des team building dans des
jardins urbains donc là c'est un petit
peu plus original le temps d'une journée
le salarié se reconnecte à la terre en
donnant un petit coup de main au jardin
potager en plus c'est tout bénef ça
sensibilise à la protection de la nature
et ça fédère les équipes parce qu'on
jardin ensemble entre collègues autre
outil assez impactant et qui est assez
en vogue aussi c'est la fresque du
climat oui alors plusieurs collègues
sont réunis dans une même pièce chacun
dispose de cartes avec des images des
chiffres des mots clés toujours en lien
avec l'urgence climatique l'objectif
c'est de coller tous ensemble ces images
sur une grande fraise en papier sur sur
le mur pour mesurer finalement l'impact
que chaque acte individuel peut avoir
sur la planète au final ça donne une
belle œuvre vivante et collective qui
donne finalement à réfléchir sur sa
responsabilité en tant que salarié mais
surtout en tant qu'être humain bon c'est
bien beau Émilie toutes ces actions mais
est-ce que ça transforme vraiment les
entreprises une fois de retour au bureau
est-ce que dans leur vie normale j'ai
envie de dire les salariés et ce qu'ils
ont eu une espèce de déclic alors
vendredi la plateforme va pas nous dire
le contraire selon elle est salarié sont
plus en plus impliqués de plus en plus
engagés d'ailleurs ils deviennent plus
exigeants et mettent plus de pression
sur leur employeur leur employeur qui du
coup elles sont obligés un petit peu
d'agir s'ils veulent retenir leurs
talents qui donc sont beaucoup plus en
quête de sens
[Musique]
pourvu que ça dure vous a été présenté
par écho DDS éco-organisme qui agit pour
une économie respectueuse de
l'environnement
[Musique]